hello everyone
i'm here today with deputy prime
minister freeland and ministers anand
fraser and wilkinson to talk about what
we
continue to do to support ukrainians
president putin continued his brutal
assault on ukraine
but ukrainians have held strong
the whole world is inspired by the
strength and intensity of their
resistance
and canada will continue to deliver
support for ukraine's heroic defense
against the russian military
yesterday we announced that we would be
sending new shipments of military
supplies including body armor helmets
gas masks and night vision goggles
today we are announcing that we will be
supplying ukraine with anti-tank weapons
systems and upgraded ammunition
of course this is in addition to our
three previous shipments of lethal and
non-lethal equipment
it's encouraging to see so many of our
partners also stepping up to deliver
support and equipment to ukraine the
international community is rallying to
support democracy and the people of
ukraine
the canadian armed forces will also be
providing airlift support to transport
supplies and aid and to contribute to
other nato efforts
since this assault began
thousands of ukrainian families have
been fleeing to escape the violence
president president putin has created a
refugee crisis
we've said we would be there for the
people of ukraine and that includes
making sure they can find safety here in
canada we have bolstered our presence in
the region and are fast-tracking
immigration applications for ukrainians
who want to come to canada
as we provide assistance to ukraine we
also continue to work with our allies
and partners to ensure
that russian aggression does not go
unpunished
over the past few days i have spoken
with many world leaders including
president biden as well as members of
the g7 and other european partners we
have discussed developments and our
concerted actions
together
we continue to take further steps to
hold president putin and his oligarchs
accountable
and to weaken russia's ability to
finance this war
they have chosen
on saturday alongside our allies and
partners we announced our support for
removing several major russian banks
from the swift payment system this will
leave these banks effectively
disconnected from the international
financial system
and to prevent the russian central bank
from undermining the impact of our
sanctions we are paralyzing its
international reserve assets
as of this morning canadian financial
institutions are barred from any
transactions with the russian central
bank
and we are prohibiting any direct or
indirect dealings in russian sovereign
debt
today we are announcing our intention to
ban all imports of crude oil from russia
an industry that has benefited president
putin and his oligarchs greatly
this industry accounts for more than a
third of russia's federal budget
revenues and while canada has imported
very little amounts in recent years
this measure sends a powerful message
in addition
it ensures
that those who are complicit in
president putin's atrocities cannot
escape the consequences of their actions
this is why it was announced that
russian oligarchs will be prevented from
using their wealth to buy citizens
citizenship abroad and avoid the
consequences of sanctions the russian
government is now experiencing the
severity of our coordinated sanctions
it is increasingly clear that president
putin has made a grave miscalculation
today the ruble plunged to record lows
and the russian stock market
was forced to close
people across russia and around the
world are taking to the streets
demanding freedom for ukraine
our message is clear this
unnecessary war
must stop now
the costs will only grow steeper and
those responsible
will be held accountable
in these difficult times it is important
to continue to rely on the facts
in russia president putin continues to
block the independent media and uses the
state-controlled media to spread
falsehoods and propaganda about his
unwarranted war
such misinformation will not be allowed
to spread in canada
the crtc is an independent body and we
will be asking them to begin the process
to review russia today's presence on
canadian airwaves
the rigorous process is important when
it comes to the independence of media in
our country
but even ahead of that decision major
providers are already removing rt
proactively
there is a significant amount of
disinformation circulating from russia
including on social media and we all
need to keep calling it out our
government will continue to be a leader
on this
those who are witnessing the truth are
seeing civilians being targeted
grandparents joining the fight families
with young children sheltering in subway
stations and people fleeing to the
border with only a suitcase
these images are heartbreaking and they
lay bear the human costs of war
to support relief efforts in the region
our government continues to provide
humanitarian aid
canadians are stepping up to help
ukrainians and we are ready to match
that help
so if you donate to the canadian red
cross ukraine humanitarian crisis appeal
our government will match your donation
up to 10 million dollars this is in
addition to the 50 million dollars for
development and humanitarian aid we've
already committed
to the people of ukraine
your bravery is truly remarkable
the whole world
is watching your courage
and your strength
we are deeply inspired as we honor your
fight for freedom for democracy and
human rights
canada stands with you
slava ukraine
mercy
[Music]
thank you prime minister
dr martin luther king believed that the
ark of the moral universe is long
but that it bends towards justice
he also knew that there are evil men in
the world
who seek to swart that benign curve
and push us all back into darkness
because of those men
there are moments in history
when the great struggle
between freedom and tyranny
comes down
to one fight
in one place
which is waged for all of humanity
in 1863
that place was getting gettysburg
in 1940
it was the skies above britain
today
in 2022
it is
cave
today
in the cobbled streets
of this golden domed city a
ukraine
is bravely positioning itself as the
moral voice
of the free world
i bow my head
in solemn respect
to ukraine and to all ukrainians
canada is proud to stand with you
but there is another side to this story
while brave ukrainian civilians
gamely learn how to make molotov
cocktails to defend their homes
one of the world's most brutal war
machines
is bombarding them
not content to terrorize his own people
president vladimir putin
is seeking to impose his tyranny on his
democratic freedom-loving neighbors
in launching this war president putin
attacked the values and the
international rules-based order
which are the foundations of all of the
democracies of the world
and in so doing
he
and his hangars on
have forfeited the right
to partake in the global prosperity
which we
the world's democracies have built
together
that is why
in partnership with europe and the
united states
and the united kingdom
we now have in place the toughest
sanctions ever imposed on a major
economy
no canadian financial
institution including the bank of canada
will transact with the russian central
bank
the entire world is now acting
russian banks from using the swift
payment system
these measures will cut russia off
financially from the western world
they will render useless
much of the war chest
that vladimir putin has amassed
in his central back
and to our russian counterparts
who are today struggling vainly to prop
up a ruble in free fall
let me say
we warn you
twelve days ago i urged the governor of
the russian central bank not to allow
her government to launch an illegal and
unprovoked war
i cautioned her
that if russia took this horrible step
it would be as tally rand reportedly
said
worse than a crime
it would be a mistake
the west's economic sanctions i warned
would be swift
coordinated
sustained
and crushing
they are
and they will continue to be
dictators
very much including the kremlin's tyrant
often fail to understand democracies
we can seem to them to be weak and
divided
compared to the servile conformity that
they impose on their societies at the
barrel of a gun
but our very openness to debate and
dispute means that once we are agreed on
a course of action
we are strong
and we are united
the people of ukraine are today showing
the incredible strength
of a free people
fighting for their democracy
and the world's democracies are equally
resolute
in our support for the brave people of
ukraine
this is one of those times and one of
those places
where freedom confronts tyranny
we are determined
that freedom will triumph and it will
slavo
and now i
hand over the floor to my colleague sean
frazier our minister of immigration
[Applause]
everyone
this is a war against democracy
and against the rights of all ukrainian
people in the face of this conflict will
stand steadfast
with the people of ukraine
we expected upon reports of a potential
further invasion into ukraine that we
would see displacement displacement of
ukrainians
that's why we started preparing more
than a month ago
to
ensure we had the ability to respond to
a potential influx
of people seeking to come to canada
since january 19th
we began processing applications in our
existing inventory or within immigration
refugees and citizenship canada on a
priority basis
to date there have been nearly four
thousand applications that have been
approved
this is across all lines of business and
we're going to continue to offer that
expedited processing
we also knew that we had to prepare on
the ground for the situation when people
would flee to the west
minister jolie was able to negotiate the
safe passage for canadian citizens
permanent residents and their families
as well
to ensure that they could escape a
potentially violent conflict
we beefed up the resources in our
offices in warsaw
and vienna and bucharest to ensure that
we would have the capacity to process
people who found themselves seeking to
come to canada or to make an application
we are prioritizing
immediately the processing of travel
documents and passports for canadian
citizens and permanent residents so that
they can return home as quickly as
possible located service channel
this is
a tool
that allows people seeking information
about the immigration process to get
information and i want to ensure that
people can get information that they can
rely on in an age of misinformation and
disinformation
for those who are seeking to get
assistance or to have information
i would urge you to call the telephone
line that we established at 613-321-4243
i'll repeat that for those who are
listening
613-321-4243
applicants and those with questions can
use the web form and use the keyword
ukraine 2022 and their web form inquiry
and their email will be given priority
once again the key word is ukraine 2022.
processing of travel documents and
passports for canadian citizens
and permanent residents
and some passports are given in as
little as 24 hours we know that you
can't go home right now
so we've taken steps to make it easier
for you to stay
we've made the decision to extend
temporary status and issue open work
permits to ukrainian visitors workers
and students who are already in canada
we are also waiving application fees for
passports permanent resident documents
proofs of citizenship veteran visas and
study and workpieces immigrants many of
whom were forced to flee war on
persecution many years ago
have helped build the country that we
love so much today
the people-to-people connections between
canadians and ukrainians
justifying an extraordinary response
and the profiles and courage that we're
witnessing is an absolute inspiration to
the world
and it's helped create an attitude of
wanting to do more
amongst the canadians that i'm speaking
with
over the past week i've heard directly
from the ukrainian canadian community
the ukrainian canadian congress and
businesses across the country on how
best to welcome ukrainians in canada
in this dark hour
we are with you
i can assure you that we're working to
prepare additional measures and in the
near future we will have more to say to
identify the best path forward to
welcome more ukrainians to canada
in the safest and quickest way possible
thank you so much i'll now share the
microphone with my colleague minister on
good afternoon bon appetit i know that
there are many canadians watching
putin's horrific attack
on ukraine who want to know how they can
help and what we as a country are doing
canada has been there for ukraine's
military and its people
over the past few years our canadian
armed forces have trained over 33 000
ukrainian soldiers to help them prepare
for the very type of attack that they
are facing today
then as russia continued to amass troops
at ukraine's border we announced last
month the extension and expansion of
that very training mission operation
unifier
since russia breached and violated
ukraine's borders we've increased our
support by approving and delivering
approximately 10 million dollars worth
of non-lethal and lethal aid to ukraine
this past month which arrived on
ukrainian soil prior to the onset of
these further hostilities
to bolster the ukrainian people's strong
resistance against putin's increasing
aggression yesterday minister jolie and
i announced that we would be providing
additional non-lethal aid ranging from
body armor to gas mass plus additional
airlift support facilitated by up to 50
canadian armed forces personnel
both to ensure that this aid gets there
and to support nato's efforts in the
region more broadly
the first such plane left for europe
today with the second later this week
and now
at the further request of ukraine and in
coordination with nato allies we are
announcing today that we are providing
even more lethal aid to ukraine
and we'll be sending 100 carl gustav
anti-tank weapon systems and 2 000
rockets which we will be working to
deliver as quickly as possible in the
coming
and the department of immigration
i want to express my deepest thanks to
our canadian armed forces for the
critical work they have done to prepare
our ukrainian friends for this fight and
who continue to answer the call to
defend canada
our allies and the rules-based
international order
slava ukraine
tv
president zlinsey's come out and ask for
nationals who want to come fight in
ukraine that they're welcome to come and
he would welcome them to come there
would the federal government support
anyway canadian citizens going to
ukraine to fight against the russians
i think all canadians have been inspired
by how president zielenski and the
people of ukraine have stood up against
this russian onslaught
following along on social media and our
nightly news as seeing the images of
people defending their homeland i can
understand why so many
proud ukrainian canadians
are looking to support in any possible
way we have
put forward
ways to donate through the red cross to
help people directly
i know people are talking about opening
their homes and their communities to
people fleeing and indeed
some canadians may choose to take more
active steps
we will of course look at ways to make
sure that we're keeping canadians safe
that remains our priority every step of
the way
and we encourage canadians as we have
been for many many
months
many weeks anyway
to leave ukraine if they're in ukraine
right now
you mentioned in your remarks that
civilians are being targeted by the
residents right now that's an assessment
that the ukrainian government agrees
with but they say that's war crimes do
you think that what the russians have
done in ukraine right now constitutes
war crimes
we have seen over the past couple of
days
that putin made a grave miscalculation
he thought it would be
easy to
conquer ukraine to take over its capital
city
he thought the west would be divided and
uncertain
in its response
and thought he had accounted for any of
the sanctions that we would bring
forward
he was terribly wrong on both counts
the
west
and indeed countries around the world
are united in standing up for ukraine
not just
for ukraine
but for the principles of democracy
and the rule of law that has led to
tremendous prosperity and stability in
our world
over the past 75 years
and people around the world are united
in recognizing that you cannot
upend
75 years of peace and stability
and hope to continue
to benefit
from the economic largesse
of those 75 years of peace and stability
which is what we have demonstrated
and further
the courage
the resilience of the people of ukraine
and standing up to defend their homeland
has inspired us all
but has surprised putin
and unfortunately we are seeing him
stepping up
in the intensity of the attacks
in the
broadness of targets including
increasingly civilian and infrastructure
targets
they're absolutely unacceptable
putin's crime is to have chosen to
invade
a peaceful neighboring country and
violate the u.n charter and the
principles of sovereignty and
territorial integrity and the world will
not
stand by idly and watch it happen
a question
regarding
the displacement of people and visas for
ukrainians who want to come to canada i
would like to understand why we cannot
remove the requirement for having a visa
right away is there any is there a
reason why it's not being done
from the beginning we've been trying to
find the best way to
put forward
many measures
approval for visas but we are looking at
all of the tools at our disposal
in order to best help those who would
like to come to canada
canadians are there too
welcome
people who are fleeing the violence
and they're there to help
those who would like to have a new life
here in canada as
many ukrainians have done before
we are
examining the different ways of doing
things and we will choose the best way
forward to help as many people as
possible as quickly as possible but with
that i will
give the floor to
mr fraser
thank you for your question
we are working with the ukrainian
congress in order to
the ukrainian uh
find the best way forward for ukrainians
who would like to come to canada
i will answer you in english french i
hope i hope that's okay
we've been we've been looking at all of
the different options
our goal is to identify the best path
forward to allow more ukrainians to come
to canada easily and safely we're
working with the ukrainian canadian
congress to develop the best path
forward and working with different
provincial counterparts as well to
understand the opportunities to do this
the right way and the most effective way
i hope that answered your question i was
trying carefully to uh to follow
not exactly but it's okay
on another note
every day your government has announced
sanctions
military support with sending
more weapons
should we be concerned
about
russia's reaction
who has threatened nuclear weapons
answer that's a very good question
we talked about this
this morning
i talked about this with g7 leaders and
with president biden
and i can say that
some
we want to show
break this piece that has been in europe
for over 75 years
is to stay firm and united
and to show vladimir putin that he made
a horrible mistake that he miscalculated
and that he will have to
stand back next question
global news in english on the nuclear
threat what is your analysis of
president putin's decision this weekend
we had a direct discussion about this
amongst allies this morning president
biden and g7 leaders and others
as we talked about this
obvious this concern
but we agreed that we stand resolute and
determined
to demonstrate that
you cannot violate
years of peace and stability in europe
and then turn around and expect to be
able to benefit from profit from and
enjoy the fruits
of that stability and the growth that
that stability brought us all
we are
firm
and determined
to continue
to stand strong together in defense of
democracies we will not
look to provoke
we will not look to escalate
but we will stand in defense of the
values
and the freedoms
that canadians and americans and
europeans and people around the world
have fought for and fought to preserve
over the many decades past
does raising the alert level of russia's
nuclear forces change anything about the
posture of the canadian armed forces
we continue
to hope for and look for
de-escalation
we continue to hope that
russia will see
that this was a terrible mistake
and withdraw its forces from ukraine
because we will not
be backing down
on the economic measures and sanctions
that we have put forward
to demonstrate to putin and his
cronies
that they cannot
violate the police the peace and
stability
that we've seen in this world
and expect to benefit from it personally
and in their families
but on the military i'm happy to turn to
minister anat
so putin's use and language relating to
nuclear capabilities highly
irresponsible
and bellicose then
i condemn it in the strongest terms
in terms of the canadian arms force
armed forces themselves
of course
we are
participating in nato
reinforcement activities as part of
operation reassurance
in nato's eastern flank
we announced last week that we are
bolstering our 500
plus presence
there with an additional
capacity of up to 460
soldiers operating on air land and sea
we are also of course standing by
temporarily in poland
where we hope to begin operation
unifier once again
in the future
but i want to be clear
canadian armed forces members
are assisting with the deterrence
and defensive
principles on which nato
is based
we also stand ready
of course
with our nato allies
if there were to be a breach
and an occasion to invoke article 5
of the washington treaty
which states
essentially that an attack on one is an
attack on all
we
as a country are deeply committed to
deterrence and defense
and we will work
with our nato allies
to protect the international rules-based
order
and the sovereignty and stability
of ukraine
thank you
we'll take one last question in the room
before going to the phone
ashley burksbcu's minister onan actually
um
where are you getting this lethal aid
from is it being taken from the calf
inventory is it leftover stock purchase
for the kurds or is this something
you're buying specifically for ukraine
this is from
canadian armed forces inventory
the 125 launchers those are the carl
gustav anti-tank weapon systems
the 2000 rockets
ammunition essentially
that our allies are using and
in fact our ammunition has been upgraded
here
ukraine is asking for this
in addition to the lethal aid that we've
already provided and so yes the answer
to your question it's from caf inventory
thank you
and prime minister when do you expect
ukraine to receive the latest shipment
of this lethal aid and juvenile concerns
that canada publicly speaking about
sending more lethal aid could further
provoke russia's president
you'll note that i rarely provide
details regarding the path that our
deliveries of lethal aid
takes
and the reason is underlying your in
your question
because we want to make sure
that the aid arrives in good time and in
good hands
so what i can say is that we are
coordinating with our nato allies to
ensure the safe passage of this aid
and it would be imprudent for me to
provide further details at this time for
the safety and security of the canadian
armed forces and for the safe passage of
the ammunition and the weapons
themselves thank you
questions on the phone
thank you merci the first question is
from uh charles from the toronto star
please go ahead
hi um i hope you can clarify something
for me
just on the rt
edge the taking and i'm gonna take
tonda you're cutting in and out a little
bit uh can you maybe start over again
can we raise the volume a little bit in
the room please
sorry is this better yes sounds better
yeah
um can you clarify on rit the crtc has
yet to take action on other state-owned
media outlets from other countries
including two chinese networks that have
aired forced
confessions and so if you're calling for
a review of russian propaganda
being shared in canada
will you also be pushing for action on
disinformation from
networks in other countries
uh thank you for the question i think
it's it's a good question one we should
absolutely and are indeed reflecting on
uh right now uh because of the conflict
in ukraine because of the importance
of ensuring that people around the world
are getting accurate information as to
russia's choice
to invade ukraine
russia's choice
to kill ukrainian civilians
russia's choice
to violate
the territorial integrity of ukraine and
indeed
the principles of peace and security
that have held sway for so long and led
to so much prosperity around the world
it is important that
canadians and people around the world be
faced with accurate information that is
why we have asked the crtc to begin the
process
of
removing rt from its airwaves but from
canada's airwaves but we recognize the
crtc is an independent body and this
process is important because
the independence of journalists of media
in this country is something that we
have to take great care in
but even as this process is lo is to be
launched through the crtc
i was very pleased to see
a number of major carriers of news and
information and networks
across this country
making the choice
to ban russia today because of the
nature of propaganda and
certainly there can be a reflections of
other countries that engage in
misinformation but right now with the
ukraine crisis
our focus is on that
following up
[Music]
yes thanks um i would like some clarity
yesterday minister anand said a combat
mission is not on the table at this time
for canadian troops
and you have all spoken about
being ready to defend nato but i want to
understand
what you mean by a combat mission in
ukraine
is not on the table at this time
what would be a what is your trigger or
threshold
that would
put canadian troops into a combat
mission in ukraine
is it the deployment of nuclear weapons
that decision tonda is one to be made by
our allies together
nato is a defensive alliance that has
agreed uh to work together and has
worked extraordinarily well together for
many decades now in
keeping peace uh in
europe and indeed elsewhere around the
world
any decision to
shift
nato's posture
needs to be taken by nato leadership
itself uh
indeed the countries collected in nato
on thursday on friday morning
we had a nato leaders summit
where we discussed our vision for the
future the way we were going to be
working together
and it is clear
that we are not
going to be sending troops into ukraine
last question
[Music]
and if that is the case what would
canada
what would canada recommend to those
people
that the situation is very difficult for
a lot of people
in russia who disagree
with
vladimir putin
vladimir putin's decision and the
kremlin's decision
leave russia
we will do our best to help them
recognize that the situation is
very
difficult for weeks
we have been encouraging people to be
careful when traveling to russia or to
ukraine
who have removed flights from russia so
what is canada ready to do
if they need to repatriate
canadians in russia
[Music]
canada
decided this weekend to close off
its airspace to russian aircraft
this is an important decision
which shows
russian aircraft and private
russian aircraft will not be able to go
through
canadian airspace to
go on
business trips or on vacation these are
part of the measures that we are
implementing
because the
russian government
is well aware
of
the barbaric act
in ukraine
we will
continue to offer assistance
to all canadians in difficulty
throughout the world but we recognize
recognize that the situation is very
difficult
today's press conference thanks all